[Music]
on this Saturday night travel plans
derailed on Planes Trains and
Automobiles from the snarl stranding Sun
VIA Rail passengers they've run out of
food on the train and the stray dogs
with no way to get to their new homes
were devastated we're disappointed too
to airlines that keep canceling flights
yet another restriction some of our
worst nightmares are coming true the
taliban's latest decree to diminish
women's rights in Afghanistan
and from newsmakers and money makers
yeah I don't think so to memorable
moments Mike Armstrong's quirky take on
the past year from A to Z
global national
reporting tonight Pauline Christie good
evening thanks for joining us extreme
weather is creating a challenging
Christmas Eve for many Canadians
Environment Canada has issued weather
warnings for most provinces and
territories tonight thousands of people
are without power in several provinces
airports across the country are still
dealing with delays and cancellations
hundreds of VIA Rail passengers were
stranded overnight between Toronto and
Montreal and there are now flood
concerns in BC as the temperatures rise
and a wallop of snow turns to water no
matter where you are tonight there's a
good chance the weather is playing a
role in your holiday plans nitogarcha as
our top story
a northern Manitoba these volunteers are
known to rescue dogs now this group says
it needs a Christmas miracle
after more than 120 dogs from Winnipeg
were on board a truck on their way to
their new homes in Newfoundland and
Labrador the winter storm hitting
communities across Canada forced them to
turn back from Thunder Bay Ontario on
Thursday we're devastated we're
disappointed what we're looking for is
somebody that you know maybe has a
private plane or some company an airline
that can do this founder of rescue NL
Heather Ballard says there's an urgent
need to transport the dogs I would say
it's a crisis actually there's an
overpopulation of animals because a lot
of them are not spay and neuter some of
these communities you know are flying
fly only and the temperatures are so
frigid that the longer it takes for
these dogs to come to Newfoundland the
longer those other dogs are waiting and
uh it's just it can be fatal for them
the group is hoping someone somewhere
will be able to step in and help them
fly to their new homes
and while hundreds of flights especially
out of Vancouver International Airport
had to be canceled this week because of
the snowstorm stranding some passengers
for days in the terminal experience has
been awful first time flying on my own
as well I had a friend who was stuck
here for a couple days on Monday and
Tuesday the airport's CEO says things
are much better on Christmas Eve some
cancellations are coming through because
of weather events in other parts of the
country and other parts of the continent
but for the most part we are operating
as normal here at ybr
as BP's Lower Mainland now contends with
heavy rainfall in Quebec nearly 300 000
Hydro customers woke up on Saturday
without power after heavy winds and a
flash freeze overnight it's unfortunate
but definitely there will be customers
without power Monday and Tuesday a
similar situation in New Brunswick where
a winter storm caused one of the largest
province-wide power outages in decades
and for Saskatoon Environment Canada has
issued a snowfall warning leading into
Christmas morning which is when these
volunteers hope the dogs they're trying
to help will somehow have been able to
make it from Winnipeg to their new homes
we do need a Christmas miracle to make
it happen in Newfoundland and Labrador
nitugaricha Global News
the storm has also trapped hundreds of
holiday Travelers overnight on trains
between Ontario and Quebec via rails
says several trains running between
Windsor and Quebec City were canceled or
forced to stop due to power outages and
downed trees passengers reported being
stuck for hours with dwindling Food
Supplies and out of service bathrooms
and I'm really ready to go home and uh
it's supposed to be a five to six hour
ride but it turned out to be more than
20 hours so it's really frustrating VIA
Rail has apologized to its passengers
saying those affected will receive a
full refund but the troubles don't end
there a CN rail wagon has derailed near
Grafton Ontario via says because of that
it's now canceling all of tomorrow's
scheduled trips headed out of Toronto to
Ottawa and Montreal
well plenty of American Travelers are
also going nowhere fast tonight because
of brutal winter weather even people in
states with sunshine and no snow are
affected Jennifer Johnson explains why
on what should be a Merry Christmas Eve
millions of Americans are still
struggling to get to their loved ones
Airlines continue to cancel flights as
blizzard conditions high winds and
bitter cold temperatures make their
final pass through the U.S it's been
canceled delayed moved to another flight
going to a different Airline now I'm
just like a little someone please get me
there over 15 000 flights were either
canceled or delayed on Friday and
cancellations continued into Saturday
even Travelers leaving Sunny Los Angeles
couldn't get out because so few planes
could make it in from other parts of the
country I thought it was safe I'm in
California and I'm headed to Hawaii
as the bomb Cyclone moved East whiteout
conditions closed highways and Roads a
50-car pileup led to at least four
deaths on the Ohio Turnpike this is a
stark reminder of what can happen when
you get behind the wheel and try to
drive
in bad weather conditions
high winds and Arctic cold air have
knocked out power to almost 2 million
Americans low temperature records are
being shattered as far south as Florida
and Texas it's cold out here today
thousands of homes in the Dallas and
Houston areas are without heat and
electricity as the state's power grid
struggles again I felt like we were in
the freezer it was really really cold
you can see our breath when we talked
others are getting frozen out on their
Christmas celebrations with so many
cancellations and re-bookings flights
through Monday are booked solid
frustrated ticket agents have been
unable to help frustrated Travelers find
alternative flights I was in this line
for like two hours and I still wasn't
able to even make it to the kiosks so
I'm just calling it The Wicked weather
Grinch has stolen Christmas this year
for many Americans in this once in a
generation storm
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
on this Christmas Eve Horror in Here
song coming up the Russian attack in
Ukraine that's left at least 10 dead
and how the Taliban is expanding
restrictions on women and girls in
Afghanistan
in Ukraine Russian shells pummeled the
southern city of her song Killing at
least 10 people and injuring dozens more
The Barrage came as ukrainians were
beginning Christmas festivities
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
posted several graphic photos of the
wreckage saying this is not sensitive
content it's the real life of Ukraine
it's killing for the sake of
intimidation and pleasure today marks 10
months since the start of the Russian
invasion violence has escalated in
Harrison since the Ukrainian Army
reclaimed the city in November
women's rights in Afghanistan have been
dealt another blow the Taliban has now
ordered all local and foreign
non-governmental organizations to Bar
female employees from work the move
comes days after female students were
banned from universities Global's
Mackenzie gray now on the latest attack
on women's rights and freedoms
[Music]
Afghan women dispersed by water cannons
as they protest their ban from
universities
but the chance of education is our right
could not be drowned up
protester yelling Howard's cowards as
they were forced to leave the site
we have come today to demand our right
to study an education center they forced
us to come into this Narrow Street then
used water cannons on us they're scared
of our voices we want our rights but the
Taliban haven't just stopped at
universities they've now barred female
employees from working at
non-governmental organizations the
ministry of economy said the ban was
necessary because they claim some women
did not follow Islamic dress code
clearly it has been
um one one horrendous decision after the
other and so clearly some of our worst
nightmares uh are coming true ngos have
played an essential role in Afghanistan
since the Taliban retook control last
year the United Nations estimates nearly
25 million people require humanitarian
assistance with 12 million people
receiving food from the UN world food
program their special representative to
Afghanistan called the ban a clear
breach of humanitarian principles for
ngos like Canadian women for women in
Afghanistan who have helped train more
than ten thousand Afghan teachers the
ban represents a significant challenge I
believe that women over already and an
open peasant for the past 16-17 months
and today Afghanistan became an open
grave for them Global News reached out
to the minister of International
Development to ask what the federal
government would do to help Canadian
ngos who work in Afghanistan but Colleen
harjit sajan's office didn't provide a
comment
Mackenzie gray and Ottawa thanks
Mackenzie
a massive kova 19 outbreak in China has
become the world's largest according to
reports estimates from the Chinese
government's health authority State
nearly 37 million people may have been
infected with the virus on a single day
this week China is seeing a dramatic
surge in coveted cases since it dropped
its strict restrictions following
widespread protests in recent weeks
a global national tradition just ahead a
look back at the year that was from a to
zed
as 2022 winds down it's impossible not
to compare how this year started how
it's closing out some things haven't
changed covet is sticking around but a
lot has happened some good some bad some
downright ugly so now a global national
tradition Mike Armstrong's Reflections
and rundown of the past 12 months in
alphabetical order
it is impossible to look back at 2022
and not compare how we started the year
to where we are now we're not completely
over covered but at least we're heading
in the right direction so A is for Abel
we're able to go to restaurants movies
and get together over the holidays with
friends and family that's progress
so here's the list
[Music]
it's for bounce gas prices are at their
lowest price all year hopefully they
don't bounce back up remember last
summer this prizes don't make sense a
lot of people got hurt C is for crypto
we could have gone with collapse I got
10 folks right there turns out this
Super Bowl ad was on the nose it's FTX
even though it was supposed to be
tongue-in-cheek yeah I don't think so
yeah
D is for delivery the pope visited
Canada in July to deliver an apology
even referring to the evil of
residential schools
e is for Elizabeth Canada and the
Commonwealth lost a queen of 70 years
she was mourned and celebrated I'm
failing up and down
F is For Freedom Convoy whatever side
you're on we can all agree it's kind of
sad that the part of Wellington Street
in front of parliament has never
reopened
G is for Gorbachev the last leader of
the Soviet Union passed away this year
one of the men responsible for ending
the Cold War and the nuclear arms race a
Nobel Peace Prize winner and it was
earned
each is for Hurricane Fiona it battered
the Bahamas
attacked Atlanta Canada by the time it
hit ground here it was a tropical storm
but it still ended up as the most costly
extreme weather event ever for that part
of the country these might as well have
been Lego toys there was there was no
chance times are tough now so we got to
be very careful I is for inflation now
slowing hopefully it's been tough on a
lot of people demand is unlike anything
we've ever seen we the jury J is for
Johnny Depp there were details in that
case I could have done without but it
was kind of hard to look away we must
find an Implement K is for King Charles
it doesn't quite roll off the tongue
just yet worst experience I've ever had
L is for luggage it was kind of the year
of luggage problems and canceled flights
what delayed and then delayed again and
then cancel airports struggled and in
fact still are you do some would expect
some delays but I didn't expect it to be
like this I'm happy to confirm M is for
musk Elon may be proving that just
because you're good at some things does
doesn't mean you're good at everything
what else can I do n is for no more
maybe we could take just like
two years without superhero movies
yes yes yes yes
no O is for overturn which is what the
US Supreme Court did to Roe versus Wade
not quite the settled law some justices
claimed in their confirmation hearings
today I had to look people in the eye
and turn them away
for pig heart doctors were able to
implant one in a human great news but
I'm still hoping to avoid it
Q is for quickly which is how most
thought the Russian invasion of Ukraine
would go
it's not
has been is absolutely brutal
R is for refugees who are on the ground
as Millions fled Ukraine mostly women
and children not knowing where they were
going only that they couldn't stay at
home
s is for Sri Lanka now this one
represents all protests they took to the
streets in China and of course in Iran
well in Sri Lanka they forced mass
resignations and at one point actually
occupied the president's home
T is for terribly which is how things
are going in Haiti country desperately
in need of help but no one can quite
figure out how to give it
U is for Uvalde the sight of a mass
shooting that left 19 children dead a
nightmare that should never happen but
does over and over I am sick and tired
of it
we have to act
V is for volcano a phenomenon as
fascinating as it is powerful there were
a few this year this was Hawaii like the
goddess returns
classified documents relating to nuclear
weapons W is for what was he thinking
there was Trump taking home top secret
documents Djokovic ending up in
detention in Australia after a supposed
mistake on his visa application
and of course the Will Smith slap I am
confident X is for ex prime minister UK
had three different ones in not even two
months
baby thank you
Y is for Yonder not a word we use often
so here it is but the James Webb
Telescope let us look further Across the
Universe we've ever seen before
and finally it's usually tough to find
something for Zen not this year
we'll go with Vladimir zielinski he has
led his country through incredibly
difficult times and become for his
people a symbol of Courage confidence
and Hope
trying to wrap up a list like this one
he's exactly the sort of inspiration you
look for Happy New Year and the best of
the holidays
and happy holidays our pets celebrate
Christmas next
and that is global national for this
Christmas Eve a few weeks ago we asked
to see your furry friends in the festive
spirit and you came through so back by
popular demand our second annual
Christmas Eve Montage of holiday themed
pet photos without further delay here it
is thanks for watching hope to see you
again tomorrow I'm Colleen Christy for
Donna Farah and all of us here at global
national Merry Christmas and have a
wonderful night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you